うんと あの もう一回この四念処経を読んでみようかなということで
あの この前一回 まあ勉強をやりましたけど
どの高子の四念処経を一度お話をしてまとめて
テキストでも作ると 後の人の役に立つ可能性もあります
で 今度お話は同様にするかどうかわかりませんだけど
ただの勉強のような感じでやるか
まあ瞑想中心にやるかという二つのやり方もあります
サティパッッターナスッタというパーリ語の名前
サティっていうのはこの
まあ気づくということで
まあパッッターナっていうのはまあやっぱり
うん なかなかこれには意味が言いにくいんですね
まあ何かを作る方法とかね
建てる方法とかね やり方というふうなね
意味なんですね パッッターナっていうのは
いわゆるサティの実践方法っていうふうな意味なんですね
いわゆるサティっていうのはどのようにあの実践すれば良いかというパッターナ
サティパッッターナ ですからこの--まずはそちらだから
そちらから行けばいいのに
[笑い]そうすると中に入る
[笑い]かなりうるさいんだからね
で あのずっとあの これはやっぱりこのサティというそのものについての経典ではあります
えーと
エーワンメースタングエーカンサマヤンバガヴァクルースーリヤルティカンマーッサダンマンナマンクルーナンニルモタトラコバガヴァビククアマンテーシビッキャ
ウティバダンテーティテービククバガヴァトパッチャッソーソンバガヴァエータデボウチェ
で 場所なんですね 場所と時間なんですけど
やっぱり時間っていうのはあまり経典に出てこないんですね
まあ全部後でまとめて編集しましたからね
で ある日になってまして
クル クルという あの ある地方クルット州かな
で クルット州にあのカンマーッサダンマという名前の
あの ニガマっていうのはかなり大きな村ですね
普通の小さな村ではなくて
まあ町よりは大きいんですね
やっぱり町ですね で そちらに住んでいた人々はこのクルという名前の人々なんですね
いわゆる  [咳]まあ別に民族とか
まあその その これでこの経典を教えますかと
それでこのどんなテキストかちょっと隠れませんけど
どんなテキスト これですか持ってるの
で 二番目 そのパーリ語のテキストの
エーカーヤノーアヤン
ビックウェー マッゴー サッターナン ヴィスンディヤー ソーカ パリンダワナン サマティックマーヤ ドゥッカ
ドーマナッサーナン アッタングマーヤ ニャーヤッサ アディカマーヤ ニッバーナッサ サッチキリヤーヤ
ヤディダ
ン チャッターロー サティパッターナー カタメー チャッターロー イダ ビックウェー ビックーカーヤカー
ヤーヌ パッシー ヴィーヒャル ヴィーヤータピー サンパジャノー サティマー ヴィナーヤローケー アビッジャー ドーマナッサン
っていう風にあの四つ
このこの二で あの全部経典の内容はまあ言って終わっちゃうんですね
ヴェーダナー
スヴェーダナーヌ パッシー ヴィーヒャル ヴィーヤータピー サンパジャノー サティマー ヴィナーヤローケー アビッジャ
ー ドーマナッサン チッテー チッターヌ パッシー ヴィーヒャル ヴィーヤータピー サンパジャノー サティマー
ヴィナーヤローケー アビッジャー ドーマナッサン ダンメー スダンマーヌ パッシー ヴィーヒャル ヴィーヤータピー
サンパジャノー サティマー ヴィナーヤローケー アビッジャー ドーマナッサン
で それで あの全部経典の内容
これから何を説明するかという内容が入っている
まああの 暗記するために作っている経典でもあるし
ですからこのその暗記しやすく覚えやすくしているんです
それからこの これはかなりあの
一般の人々も結構暗記しているんです
これ長いんだけど あの
結構暗記しているんですね
で 私も子供の頃 まあお寺で行った時はやっぱり信者さんたちがね
まあ当時の まあみんな夜ゆっくりと
もう朝までこの暗記して
もうあげるんですね あの修行に来たら
今の人々は覚えてないみたいですけどね
ですからこの まあ三十五年ぐらいの前まではやっぱりほとんどの人々は覚えていたっていうことですね
だからこの四つのあの実践方法を紹介するときは
このエーカーヤノという言葉がありまして
これはワンウェイということで
唯一の道 これしか道がないということなんですね
という意味で一般的には理解しているんです
[紙をめくる音]でも
エーカーヤナっていうのは
日本語で訳せていないね
一度って書いてあります
ん？ いち 一度  一度？ 一度
どこに？ 十番  ふんふん
あ 一度です で あのパーリで言えばアヤンマッゴというパーリの言葉みたい
アヤンマッゴ この道は
という意味で ビクエ ビックレ
ビクラよ この道はエーカーヤナ
という風に訳しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから一度であるではなくて
この あ まあそうするとその風にもなりますからね
この道はまあ一度であるという風になっちゃいますけどね
で この道はエーカーヤナ
この道はまあ一つのというか
唯一の道であると あまり他のところでは
まあそういう風に このあまりにも激しく
あの言葉は出て  まあ一応僕が言ってるのは
まあほとんどあの変証できないまあ
風には言ってますけどね
まあ真理は語ってるんだけど
これしかないよ これしかないよという風にワサワサと言う必要もないんですね
そこまでお釈迦様は品格落ちてなかったんです
私こそ真実を語ってるんだと
他の人の真実を聞くなとかね
そういうふうなことはないし
逆にじゃあ私言ってることは嘘やと
できれば証明してみなさいと
で そういう風に言うんですね
ですから 一応オープンにもしておくんですね
オープンにしておくのはどういうことかというと
もう真理だから まあ別にどうったことないんですね
誰がどのように研究してみたっても
真理を発見する人は同じ真理を発見するはずですと
そこで他の人は真理を発見しないとお釈迦様はどうしますかというと
他の人と違う意見を言う場合は
その人の方法論を それはまあちょっとあのね
あの認識学的な立場でね
エピステモロジーっていう哲学の分野がありまして
お釈迦様はかなりエピステモロジーというものを使っていたんですね
で エピステモロジーっていうのは認識学でしょう
おそらく わかりません
で 認識方法 で 他の人々は違うことを言うと
お釈迦様はもの あなた言ってることは嘘嘘っていう風なことではなくて
まあこの人は真面目に真理を探求しているんだけど
なんか変なこと結論出してるんだっていうことだから
やっぱり方法論をもう一度調べてみるんですね
そうすると 相手方に あなたはこのように観察したんだけど
それは正しい観察の仕方ではありませんと
ただ 正しい観察の仕方っていうのは
パーリ語でいつでも使っている言葉っていうのは
このヤターブータン・パッセティ
まあ如実に見ると なる日本語でよく人気のあるこのありのままに見るという言葉はその訳なんですね
で 日本語では一般的な言葉になってますけど
ありのままに見るっていう
全然意味はわかってないんですね
ありのままに見るってどういうことかと
ただボケーっとして見ることだと思ってるんですね
だからあの この仏教の世界で言うのは
ボケーっとして放っておいて見るということではありのままに見ることにはなりません
ですから この それからヨーニソマナシーカーラという言葉ありまして
で ヨーニソマナシーカーラはパーリ語になって
日本語になると うーんと
難しい  ん？ 如実なる意識の
あ ニョリサイと訳していますからね
それでわかるでしょう
ニョ ニョっていうのは
まあ如という感じと あの論理の理と
あのサっていうのは作るということ
意ですね あの意識の意
そうするとニョリサイですね
そういう意味なんです
[笑い] で  [笑い]でもその意味なんで
本当は 理っていうのは理なんでしょ？ものの
その理のごとく意識を働かせることなんです
ヨニソ マナシカラっていうのは
いい加減に自分の感情で感覚で自分の好き嫌いで見るんじゃなくて
理のごとく見て見ればいいんです
だからそれありのままっていうことなんですね
ですから 決してこのニョリサイっていうことは
まああの まあ間違って入れてる言葉でもなくて
まあよく考えて入れてるんですけど
まあ一般的に使ってないだけのことなんですね
一般的に我々理にかなってるとかね
で 理にかなってるの場合
理ってどういう意味ですかね
言ってることは正しいっていうことでしょうね
論理的っていうことでしょうね
ですから まあニョリサイかもしれませんだけど
まあそれはもう一般的には使わない言葉ですけど
ヨニソ マナシカラの場合は
やっぱりこの一応ヨニソっていうのは原因ということで
どのようにこういう現象ができたんだと
なぜそういう現象がどのような過程でどのように生まれて消えていくんですか？という
このしっかりと観察する
ですから因果法則なんですね
だから因果法則を発見することになっちゃうんですね
だから ありのままに見ると
誰でも因果法則を発見するはずなんです
そこで何か変なことを言っちゃったら
その人の認識論的な この言えばこの知識を得た方法はね
もうちょっと調べなくちゃいけないんですね
そこはこのブラフマジャーラ スッタという長部経典の第一番目の経典で
その特色は見えるんです
で 何すーということかというと
そちらまあ簡単に見えますから
ざっと読んでみてください
このお釈迦様は 哲学的に
この認識医学の立場から
この人々の哲学を分析しているんですね
うん まあ一つだけ言いますけどね
あまりそういうことは喋りたくないし
あの 例えば魂は無限であると
無限というのは この魂に対しては
この時と空に分けて見ると
時間的にも無限であって
空間的に無限でもあるという二つありますけど
それまたきめ細かく分析するんですね
魂の空間的な有限か無限か
時間的に有限か無限かとかね
で そこで哲学的に論をね
まあ二つに分けて それで時間的な
まあ有限無限というところがあって
それは二つであって だからまあ
それ それから空間的には有限か無限かということは出てきて
その二つを合わせると
またたくさん出来上がっちゃうんですね
空間的には有限ですけど
時間的には無限だと やはり魂は小さいんだけど
永遠ですよということなんですね
で それもう一つは 魂は空間的にも時間的にも無限ですよと
魂は巨大で大きくて またさらに永遠ですよということになるし
もう一つありまして で
魂はまあ時間的には有限で
空間的には無限であるということで
魂だから無限に広げる大きいものなんですけど
まあ時間的には有限であると
まあ死んじゃいます いつか消えちゃうんですよと
そのように同じ我にしても
いろんなことを考えることはできるんですね
そういうのは論理的な考え方ですから
それほど仏教では論理はほとんど評価していない
理屈だけはね 理屈っていうのは数学と同じことだから
あの いくらなんでも広げることはできるんですね
数学っていうのは抽象的なもので
存在するものではありません
ですから 数学的なものを作る
あの 方程式作ったり いろんなことを考えたりすることはいくらでもできる
でも 数学で言ってることは
実際の世界に当てはめてみると
もう全て完璧に当てはまるということはないんですね
実際の世界に全く当てはめられない
あの 数学は言えます で
同じく論理学論も同じなんですけど
特にこのシンボリックロジックという
この論理がありますね
あのシンボルで論理を構成していく
で その場合はまた現代数学も使っていろんな論理を発展していくんですね
でも最終的に じゃあ実際の例を出してみなさいと言ったら
例は出せなくなっちゃうんです
だからシンボリックロジックというのはかなり発展している学問ですからね
まあ私は知りませんだけど
で 最初はね まあ簡単ですけどね
例えばAというプロポジションがあって B
というプロポジションがあるとすると A
はBですよというと で
まあ論理的にはAイコールBになります
そうすると数学なんですけど
でもAはBですよということは
論理的には世の中で例を出さなくちゃいけないんです
これなかなか大変なんです
ないんです そこでこのシンボリックロジックの初めのプロポジションなんで
今は言ったの スタート
そこからそちらに そちらにもなかなか実例出せないんですね
まあ一応出してるのは
例えばAは人間であるといえば B
は まあみんな死んじゃいますよと
みんな死んじゃいますね
ですからAはBですよということは
例を出しちゃうと すべての人間が死にますよということになっちゃう
なんとなくああ そうだなとわかるでしょうに
でもAイコールBだったらBイコールAなんですね
そうすると人間 すべての人間が死にますよということは逆にすることはできません
死ぬすべてのものは人間ですよということが言えなくなっちゃうんです
間違っちゃうんですね
だからそれで困ったなと言って
またきめ細かく分けていっちゃうんですね
ですから Bっていうのは死ぬっていうことだったら B
に入る範囲はすごい大きくて A
に入る範囲は小さくてね
だからAのすべてはBですが B
のすべてはAではありませんというようなことじゃいけないんですね
それにそれなりのシンボルを使って
まあどんどん広げていくんですね
とにかく哲学 論理学を広げていくんだけど
あの 何だかんだ実例は出てこなくなっちゃいます
で 数学の場合も同じことで
いくらでも数学は語れますけど
作れますけど 実際に の世界では例はなくなっちゃうんですね
そういうことだから この昔々のね
お釈迦様の時代では あの
あんまり論理だけっていうのはね
なんかあまり人気ないんですね
お釈迦様だったらすごくこれ気に入らないんですよ
お釈迦様は論理 論理的だと言われたら
行って攻撃する 黙ってはいないんです
だからかなり嫌でしたでしょうと思います
誰かがお釈迦様はまあよく論理的で喋りますと言ったら
もう 目の前で言うところではなくて
どこかそこのところで誰かがそういう話を広げちゃうとそこに行くんです
行って攻撃していく 結構論理はもう
すごく嫌でしたね ですから
そういう例はあるんですね
ですから お釈迦様の立場っていうのは
単なる純粋論理 ピオロジっていうのは意味がないんですね
いくらでも回転していくんだから
ピオロジじゃなくて アトリカビリティ
パッティ パッティカビリティという
この実用って何て言いますか
実際の人間の生き方にどれぐらい当てはめるかと
だから人間の生き方そのものが一番大事であって
そこを抜きに論理だけは発展させません
ですから お釈迦様はそうではなくて
あの人間生きてること
存在そのものについて研究して
そこはシステムを体験して
それを喋ってるんですね
そこはたまたま論理的になったんです
たまたま厳密な論理的になっただけ
だからそれは当たり前のことで
世の中にあることだから A
ある時Bが生まれるんだと
ということで AとBの間で
あの 何て言いますか 必然的な関係が生まれてくる
英語で言えば このインベアリバル relation という言葉も使っちゃうし
あとはお釈迦様が使ってる言葉なんですけどね
で 因果法則を語る場合はね
あのタタタ アヴィタタタ
アナンジャタタ イダッパッチェタタと 4つのこの
あの特色で因果法則を説明してますね
因果法則についていっぱい講義しましたからね
まあ私ほど私よりも理解していると思いますから
そこら辺は説明しません
え  [咳]インベアリアリティー
サステンシャリティーとか
もう一つ何でしたっけ？これ英語の単語は結構難しいんです
あの まあ一般の日本語で言えば A
からAがあるときBが生まれるというと
AとBの間はもう必然的な関係が生まれている
ですから AがあるときBがあるんであって A
があるときたまたまBがあるっていうわけじゃないんです
あるいはほとんどAがあるときBがあるっていうわけじゃないんです
このほとんど たまたま
時々 AがあるときBが生まれるときもあって
生まれないときもありますよという五分五分は絶対ありえないんです
因果法則では Aがあるならば
そこにBという ですからインベアリアリティー
インベアリアブル ということだから
論理的になってしまっちゃうんです
それはちょっと説明に行ったんだけど
一応経典は一般的に進めていきたいと思ってますから
まあ少々余計なことを言っただけで
そこら辺でやめます ただ
このエカヤナの説明しようと思って何か読み上げただけで
あの 全部読みましょう
で あまりにも 仏教の世界っていうのはね
もうそろそろ年近いんだから
研究を始めてね まだまだ把握していないんですからね
まだ根本的にまだ 結構問題点というか
理解 解明しなくちゃいけない考え方とかね
いっぱいあります とにかく現代哲学者が言っているように
この認識論にしたって
もうちょっとお釈迦様は違うところがあります
論理性いえばすごい論理性なんですけど
西洋で発展している論理性ともうちょっと違うところがあったりもしてね
そこら辺はよくよく見ると
それお釈迦様の方が正しいことにはなっちゃうんですね
あまりにもお釈迦様は厳密なんですけど
論理者ではないんですね
お釈迦様論理的だと思ったら
言ったようにお釈迦様が怒ります
言って怒ってくるんです
自分の前で言ったら怒るのは当たり前なんですけど
どういうところで言われて言われてるんだろうと思ったら
そこへ行くんです 行って怒鳴ってくるんです
ですから このやっぱり具体的な
実際の この具体的なものを見て
そこを説明する それを論理的になるだけであって
そこから論理だけ抽象的にとってしまって
論理を回転するということはないんです
人間がそういうことをやってるんだから
結局 実際 実態っていうのはおかしいんですけど
実際の我々の問題からかけ離れていっちゃうんですね
だからそこを直そうと
私はこの瞑想する人々にもね
なんとか直そうと思うんだけど
もう怒られるだけ私はかえって
だからもう本当にもう教えにくいんです
最初からもう私たちはよく知ってるんだ
よく勉強しているんだ
で あなた方と違って我々はすっごい頭がいいんだということでかかってくる
それはいいんだけど 一旦もう頭の考え方が粉々にしたならば
やっぱり壊れちゃったんだよということは認めたくないんですね
自分の考え方 自分の理解できなかったら
あなたが悪いと私にまた向かってくるんですね
あんた言うことおかしいんだから私にわからないんだと
自分がアホだからわからないっていうことでは絶対ならないんです
だからそういう調子だったら
もう勉強には全然なりません
そこでかなり私はもうもう苦しい思いいっぱいしたんだからね
で で 私の心で悪いのはあなたでしょうと
アホでもう何も論理性がなくて
バカでもバカもそれいいところで
もう少々でも考えようとしない
自分のもう 何と言いますか
固定概念というのはほんのちょっとでも置いておいてみようとはしない
法華経を叩き込まれた人が来たら
もう絶対的にそこを土台からは足を外へ出て出してこないんですね
だから私から言われてほしがるのは
法華経はとんでもない
あれ間違ってるよと そうやって言ってほしがるんですね
これは真理を語るだけ
そういうふうに言わないんです
それはあまりにも品格がない
それだったら何でも言えるでしょうに
あなたは人間ではありませんと平気で言えるでしょうに
人間ではありませんというのは
人間でないということは
ずーっと証拠を出して出して出して
相手がその結論に至らなくちゃいけないんです
私ではなくて だからお釈迦様の対話方法っていうのは
こんなこういう この週刊誌やらね
ワイドショーでやってる感じではできません
だからこの知識レベルはいつでもワイドショーの知識レベルで
もうお腹が痛くなっちゃうしね
私は体がガタガタ それでもうどうしようもないんだから
もう一つ言いたいんだけど
言わないでしょうに 自分がこれで もう体が壊れてしまうちゃうんですね
だから結局何のために喋ってるんですかといつでも思っちゃうんですね
ですから この普通のお釈迦様のこの対話方法っていうのは
結論をお釈迦様が出すんじゃないんです
自分が結論を持ってるということは
概念を持ってるということで
自分が意見を持っていて
何か主義を持っていて
何か論理を持っていて
それは人に叩き込むだけだから
これは暗示かけることで
マインドコントロールと同じことなんですね
ですから 例えば 1と1が2になるんだよということは
先生がりんごを一つ持っじゃあもう一つりんごを持ってきましょうと
じゃあこちらりんごいくつありますか？と
で 子供が 2つあるよと言うでしょうに
じゃあ今度は野球ボールにしましょう
じゃあ野球ボールを一つ持ってきてちょうだいと
じゃあもう一つ持ってきてちょうだいと
じゃあ今野球ボールいくつありますか？と
2つあるんだと じゃあ今度は本にしましょうと
で じゃあ本 1冊持ってきてくださいと
まあ 1つ じゃあもう 1つ持ってきてください
じゃあ本いくつありますか？ 2つですよと
そうやって実際に例を持ってくる
それで 1つともう 1つ一緒になったらどうなるんでしょうかねと
それで子供が言わなくちゃいけないんです
2つになるんだと だから最初から 1足す1は2
お前勉強しろっていうのはもう変な教え方なんですね
それでわからない わからなくても
それそれですよと 冗談じゃない
1足す1は2で勉強しなさいというやり方ではないんです
で お釈迦様のこの 何と言いますか
この対話方法っていうのは
だから もう諦めて今は平気でいますけどね
結論で 前はすごく気をつけて
お釈迦様のやり方ってできるだけ守ってやろうと思ったところでも
かえって私を殴られるだけでね
正しく殴れるんだったらいいんだけど
そんな冗談で言いたいところありますけどね
で 自分を体蚊に刺されたら私に怒ることと同じなんですね
蚊に怒ればいいんだけど
なんでそこに私に怒るんですかと
そんな感じで理解しないことをね
結構批判されるしね で
理解しないし  まあ論理性ってまあそういうことだから
この なかなか説明しにくいところがいろいろあります
で とにかくこの経典の場合は
この入れ替えの一つの道でありますよという意味で一応言ってるんです
ですから まあそちらはやっぱり結論的みたいにね
あの まあいろいろ思想に関係ある経典ではないんです
だからですから あまり考えなくてもいいんです
この経典を勉強すると
で なぜならばこの方法論を語ってるんだから
論理はもうとっくにできてるはずなんです
論理はもうとっくにできていて
もう論理知ってるんですね
人々に そこで じゃあどのようにこれ実践するかっていうことで
だったらこういう風に実践しなさいと
論理できちゃっているんだから
証明出してるんだから
もうとっくに そうすると
その こういうことでこうなります
こういうことでこうなります
こういうことでこうなりますということは
よく勉強して理解したところで
じゃあ我々はこのようになるためにだったらどうすればいいんでしょうかと言えば
一つの道しかないんです
それだったら ですから
この経典の言い方と他の経典の言い方はその点で違います
とにかくこの経典は仏教をよく知っていて
理解した人に言う経典なんですね
だから仏教の内容の説明はなし
それはもう明確に自分でもうとっくにわかっていなくてはならない
その仏教の教えはわかっていた人に
そういうことだから こういう風にするんだよと
悟りの境地を得るために
他の方法はないんですよと
方法がたくさんある場合は
まあちょっとした問題なんですね
例えば風邪引いたら何を飲めばいいんですかと
風邪引いたら何を飲めばいいんですか
ん？だから風邪引いてないんだから
皆様方はね [笑い]まあ結局答えられないと思います
風邪引いたら何を飲めばいいんですかと
答えられないんです 葛根湯飲む人もいて
生姜湯飲む人もいて オレンジジュース飲む人もいて
様々な風邪薬という風に売っているもの飲む人がいて当然
ですから あれ何でしょうかね
結局は 論理的に見ると
風邪に薬はないっていうことでしょう
もし風邪に薬があるならば
風邪引いたらこれ飲もうと言うべきなの
言えるでしょうに だから皆様の経験から見ても
もう葛根湯も飲んだでしょうし
生姜湯も飲んだでしょうし
お湯だけ飲んでいたでしょうし
ビタミンCいっぱい飲んだでしょうし
みかんジュースやらオレンジジュースやらたくさん飲んだこともあるでしょうし
でも別にそれでもって風邪治ったっていうことはないんだからね
もし治ったならば それでずっとその方法でいっちゃうんです
これから風邪引いたらこれでいくぞと
そういうわけで 方法たくさんあるということは怪しいんです
いわゆるはっきりした論理わかってない
あるいは逆に風邪引いたら何を飲めばいいかというと
まあ四種類ありますよと
その四種類で自分の体質に合わせて一つ選んでくださいと言ったら
それしっかりしているんですね
四種類しかない これで私にはこの飲み物は合いますよということを選びますからね
ですから いくつかあっても構いませんだけど
しっかりしていないしてほしいんですね
だからしっかりしていないということは
風邪に薬がないということなんですね
でも頭痛の時は何飲めばいいかといえば
それほど難しくないでしょう
たくさんありますけど
その時に飲む薬はね それほど難しくはないんですね
ということは そちらには薬はあります
ちょっと下痢になったとする
じゃあ何を飲めばいいかと
その人はそんなに混乱はしませんね
これを飲めば あるいはまあ種類ぐらいありますよと
これを飲めばどうですかと
薬あります ですから この方法としてはこれもいいし
あれもいいし これもいいしということでは困るんですね
方法は一つの道でないと
で困ります だからそういうわけでお釈迦様がエーカーヤノアヤンビックネという普通の経典に出てこない
この言葉が入れてるんです
だからほんのちょっとのお釈迦様の言葉なんです
その中にこのかなりのこの考え方が裏にあるんです
真理は四つですよと言ったところも同じなんですね
四つですから 五つではありませんし
八つでもないんです 四つなんです
その裏に哲学的に論理的にすごい考え方があって
そうなるんです ですから
道ですからね 富士山登るためにどうすればいいんですかと
と言えば 数えられないほど方法ありますかね
ないでしょうに 富士山を登りたければ
もう方法はちゃんと決まってる方法あります
その方法で登れるんです
あ いろいろあってとかね
あー困ったな この質問に答えられないと
ないでしょ もし私が今風邪ひいたら何を飲む？飲む？かといったら
なんとなく何も答えられないでしょうに
今同じ質問出しちゃ 富士山に登るためにどうすればいいんですかと
誰にでも答えられるでしょうに
今答えられなくても ちょっと調べてねえ
電車でどこまで行けるかとかね
五合目までどういうふうに行けばいいんですかとかね
調べてでも言えるでしょうに
ですから 方法論についてはそうやってこの曖昧はない
認めない それは危ないんですよ
例えば人は手術しようとしている
盲腸でも何とかおかしくなっちゃって
そこで医者が 例えば自分の弟子に手術させているんだと 「
先生 じゃあ始まりますか」と 「
どこから切ってよ」と言わないでしょうに
どこでもいいんだから
どこでもいいんだから切ってよとは言わないんで
そんな場合は きちんと場所を決めてあって
そこをまた何センチ切るかと厳密に決めてあって
ですから  どこから切っても盲腸に届く
届きませんってことには
あまり意味がないんですね
うん そういうことで この方法論としてはエーカーヤナ
唯一の道になるんですね
でもこれはこのもっとまた余計な解釈しちゃうと
エーカーヤナっていうのは一つの道でしょうに
日本訳見てもね もう一つの道あるんじゃないかというふうにも
誰かに論理することもできます
いろいろ道があって これは一つの道だと
そう理解したければ そういうふうにも理解しにくいわけじゃないんです
そうすると曖昧で でもその意味はあまり
これは言葉の遊びだけですからね
あまり合わないんですね
で 道だったら目的必要なんですね
方法は何のためかと サッターナンヴィスッディア
衆生の清らかさ 清らかになるために
清浄ですね だから清浄した境地を得てね
至るためなんですね ですから
テーラワーダのあの瞑想法やらね
すべてまとめて書いてる方もヴィスッディ・マッガと言うんですね
ヴィスッディの道 浄道論ですか
清浄道論 あの清浄道論というテキストは清浄道論と名前を付けてますけど
うん で テーマになった経典と関係なく
やっぱりそのブッダゴーサ長老が清浄道論と名付けてるんですね
これ この経典にある言葉なんですね
ヴィスッディとマッガ
ヴィスッディ・マッガ
だったらやっぱりブッダゴーサ長老もちょっとおかしい
ヴィスッディ・マッガといえば四念処経なんですけど
四念処経はかなり使ってますけど
いろんなことその浄道論には書いてるんです
ヴィスッディ・マッガというタイトルで本格なれば
もう四念処経の解釈しか書けなくなっちゃうんです
うん まあとにかくこの方法ははっきりした目的があります
心の清らかさ 心というのは私が付け加えたんだけど
お釈迦様はサッターナン
衆生の清らかさのために
清らかになるために 清浄かですね
清浄かの道ですね それからソーカ・パリッダワーナン・サマティッカ・マーヤ
で このパーリ語だけぐらいは覚えておいてください
それからは別に覚えなくてもいいんです
サッターナン・ヴィスッディア
で 私も覚えてるんですからね
で まあこれぐらい覚えていたっても悪くないと思います
覚えてないんだから 私はあまりパーリ語を使わないんです
ですから まあこれぐらいでも覚えておきましょう
でも で みんなにパーリ語の言葉散々言って
我ながらなかなか頭がいいとみんな圧倒されることはできないかもしれません
そういう言葉はあまり言わないんですけど
そこを覚えておいたって自分の勉強になりますね
エーカー
ヌアヤンビッカウェーサッマッゴーサッターナヴィスッディアソーカパリッタワーナサマティッカマエドッカドーマナッサーナアッターナニャーヤッサディガマエニッ
バーナサッチキリヤイダンサッターラティパッターナカメチャッターロイという
まあ一応まあということ
まあ全部覚えてるんだけど
実際どうったことなんですけど
2番目ソーカパリッダワーナサマティッカマエ
それは日本訳はどのようになってます？どなたか読んでよ
憂いですか これは 憂い悲しみ
憂い悲しみを乗り越えるために
サマアティッカマエ 日本訳はもうすごい丁寧にやってますからね
だから 2番目の目的は憂い悲しみなどを乗り越えちゃうんですね
いわゆるあの これあの
ああ この瞑想すれば憂いも悲しみも何もない
すごいすごい奇跡が起こるんだっていうことではなくて
地震も起こりませんと
地震が起きちゃったら憂い悲しみが起こるでしょうに
だからサッパッターナの教典を実践すれば地震は起きませんね
地震が起きて人死んじゃったら
これどうせ憂やら悲しみやら苦しみやら生まれるんだから
いう風に大乗的に解釈するのではなくて
で まあそれはまあ法華経のやり方
考え方ですね で 偉大なる言祝であって
もうこの経典さえ念じれば
もう何のごとなく全部もうアホもいいとこですよ
もう分かりませんが よくも腐ってる連中はね
もうあれくらいなことを
まあとにかくこっちだってソーカパリッダワーナサマティッカマエだから人間である限りはね
人は死んだり 親戚が亡くなったり
自分の体も病気になってもう倒れたり壊れたりはしますけど
やっぱり憂い悲しみ乗り越えてるんですね
そんなことには逃げないで
あんまり気にしないと
いくともしないと そういうことで
それはちゃんと証明するために
お釈迦様のことも他のお坊さんたちのことも
あの宗教的に書いてないんです
例えば法華経と比べると
法華経は奇跡だらけ 全部奇跡だらけなんですね
ですから あれはもう嘘そのもの
法華経の嘘ということぐらい失礼なほど嘘なんです
そうだったら他の人ということには言う言葉なくなっちゃうんですね
あれほど嘘は世の中でないんですね
で 法華経だけじゃなくて
また今思い出すのはその経典だけなんです
結構あるんだけどね で
人は書くもんじゃないんです
とにかく経典なんかは勝手に
自分も怒りやら高慢やら欲やらそればっかりでね
で 書いたこと自体もおかしいでしょうね
なんかブッダではなくて
なんか他の化け物いったようなブッダも乗り越えちゃって
法華経はブッダが語ってないんだから
どっかの化け物語ってるでしょうね
遊馬経もそうでしょうね
ブッダ語ってないんでしょうね
なんかどっかの他のもう歴史的にもない
どこのどんな馬の骨かわからない遊馬居士という化け物を書いてるでしょうね
ですから まあおかしいもいいところですけど
とにかくまあそうやってブッダも置いといて
ブッダ自身をバカにして書こうと
いかに人のね もう心が腐ってるかって
だから内容はそれ分すごくおかしくなっちゃうんですね
だから逆に正直にね 私はこう思いますよと書いたならば
みんなに気持ちよく勉強できるのに
これは仏教に対する私の作品だよと
いいは まあ大変文学作品としてね
全然問題なく読める まあそこで言いたかったのはこういうこと
で 一般的なパーリ文系になると
このブッダのことも あのブッダのことはどんどんどんどんどんどん人格化になって
すごい大げさに鉄人の種類になってしまったんだけど
やっぱりそれでも人間で人間でいたことのなくなってはないんですね
あまりにもブッダのことをありがたがってありがたくて
お釈迦様簡単にやります
もう水浴びをしましたと
途中で川があって もう川で水浴びをして
それから体に水いっぱい付いてるでしょうね
そこである経典でお釈迦様は誰が喋ってるんで
その時はガッターにプッバーペーマーのその時お釈迦様自分の体を拭いてるんですよ
川から上がってきて だから普通の人間で
で 我々と同じく まあ川に
まあ川に入って体洗ったならば
まあ起き上がったら体中水いっぱいあるんだから
それはもう衣絞ってこれで体も拭いてるんですね
で 体を拭いてる間に何かお話をしているんです
それで注釈書になるとこう書くんですね
偉大なるブッダですから
三十二の人相を持ってるんだから
三十二相 お釈迦様の体には埃はたまりませんと
全然 だから水一滴もたまりませんと
でも世の中のみんなやってるんだから
まあただ水浴びをしただけですよという風に言うんだけど
あれは嘘であって あれは注釈書を書いた人は
お釈迦様のことはもうやっぱり一般人として扱うのはあまり申し訳なくて
まあ余計なことを言うだけで
それぐらいのことはすぐわかるんですね
お釈迦様の皮膚はビニールでできてるんですかと
ビニールでできたっても
やっぱりホコリ溜まるでしょうに
じゃあガラスでできてるんだ
それでもホコリは溜まっちゃいますからね
で ホコリは体につけてもすぐ出ていくんだったら
ずっとお釈迦様 あの 何て言いますか
静電いっぱい持っていなくちゃいけないんですね
それは瞬時に静電変えなくちゃいけないんですね
やっぱりそれでも埃はまあ冬になってくるんだからね
我々の体も静電もう何万ワットも静電つけちゃうでしょうね
特に私の体だったらかなり静電過ぎますから
この仮性陰茎体中まとっているんだから
逆に世の中の埃全部吸うんです
一番嫌なこの寒さではなくて
私は一番嫌なこの埃なんですね
大きな玉作れるんですよ
衣の周りで集めると あれすごいもんなんです
いくら気をつけてもダメなんです
まあだからどんな体かわかりませんだけどね
やっぱり普通にはお釈迦様
ごく普通な人間で 歳も取ったし
病気にもなりましたし
で そういういろいろなことありますね
でも じゃあなんで悟ったんだから
なんで病気になったんですかとかね
なんで体痛い痛いって言うんですかとかね
そういう意味ではないんですね
だからこの 悲しいこと
苦しいことっていうのは確かにありましたよと
でも悲しいこと 苦しいことあったんだけど
それは悲しみでも苦しみでもなかったという話なんです
お釈迦様はものすごくサーリプッタ尊者が亡くなったところで
本当にお釈迦様はなんかもう自分の手が亡くなったような感じなんですね
自分もすごく年で すごくありがたがっていた弟子もほとんど年ほぼ同じ年ぐらいで
先に行ってしまったんですね
お釈迦様はもうちょっと何年か生き続けるでしょうね
やっぱり寂しいんですよ
自分もお年だから もう誰かが助けてくれた方が大変ありがたいし
でもいつでも体のことは誰でもできますけどね
説法の世界 指導の世界はできた人が先に行ってしまって
その穴がよくわかるんです
お釈迦様の心に開いた穴が
わかるんだけど ピクともしないんですね
そういうことに でもお話はする
なんか今の比丘たちを見ると
すごく寂しいんだと 虚しく感じるんだと
なんか太陽とお月様が消えたような感じだと
自分の弟子たちを見ると
あの二人がいないんですよ
だからお釈迦様にとっては面白くないんです
だからすごく人間として素晴らしい
そのところはお釈迦様の素晴らしいところなんですね
それで落ち込んだかというと
全然落ち込んだことでもないし
やっぱり両手がなくなったような感じだという事実も語るし
ですから仏道修行するんだからって
奇跡 何から何まで奇跡が起こるんだとは勘違いして困るんです
病気は治るわ これから病気にもならないし
愁い悲しみはなくなっちゃうんだったら
論理的に考えると地震も起こりませんと
私はこれは冗談で言うんだけど
このいろんな意味で言ってるんです
なぜなら論理だけ働かせちゃうと
数学と同じく そういう論理に簡単に至れるんです
この道を実践すれば 愁い悲しみは乗り越えられるんだと
ということは 実践した者には愁い悲しみはないということ
故に 人間にとっては愁い悲しみは何でしょうかと
いえば もう子供が死ぬこと
親戚が死ぬこと 財産がなくすことっていうのは愁い悲しみでしょうね
それでどのように人間のそういうことを起こりますかといえば
地震が起きたら一発で全て消えると
それ一番大きいことですよ
病気で親戚が亡くなるよりも
竜巻が出たらもうかなり損害はする
病気になったらかなり
そういうことを人間苦しんだり悩んだりする
会社が倒産したら もうリストラになっちゃったら
クビになったらかなり苦しみが出てくる
ということは そういうことはありませんと
故にサティパッターナ経典を実践すれば地震がなくなる
会社が倒産することはなくなるというふうに論理だけでいけますよ
だからその 言わないで
僕はとても簡単に地震も起こらないんですよとそれだけ言ったんだから
結論だけね でも そういう単なる冗談ではなくて
私はちゃんと論理的に言うものなんですから
そういうふうに論理は成り立ちます
でも そこは純粋に論理であって
シンボリックロジックであって
実際とは関係ないんですね
我々のプラクティカルな世界には関係ないんですね
だから プラクティカルな世界では地震は起こる
地震が起きたら パティパッターナの実践する人と実践しない人には差があるんだと
実践しなかった人はものすごく憂いに悲しみに陥って
もう立ち上がれなくなっちゃう
で パティパッターナの人は何のことなく
ただこうして もうその時その時のやるべきことをやって
ずっと生きているんです
寂しいんだったら その人の寂しいんですよ
冬が地震 冬に地震が起きたならば
その人は寒いんですよ
その時その時のやる  そういうことですから
この そこでソーカパリッダワーナ サマティッカマエ
これ乗り越える 消すではないんです
心にはないんですね そういう事件は起こる
でも心にはソーカパリッダワーナ
憂い悲しみは生まれません
次にドゥッカドゥーマナッサーナン アッタガマエ
これは何でしたっけ？訳は
苦しみと憂い 前にあったの何でしたっけ
憂いと悲しみ 乗り越える
次にあるのも憂いですか？読み方
苦しみと  と何？ 憂いが消え
幸せを得  それも憂いですかね
漢字が違うんだけど なんか意味
意味どうでしょ 意味は同じです
ドゥッカドゥーマナッサっていうのはこの調もあると思います
ドゥッカっていうのは普通の苦しみですね
体で感じる苦しみ ドゥーマナッサっていうのは心で感じる悲しみ
あの分析すれば分析できますけどね
ソーカパリッダワーナっていうのは外のことなんです
自分の身体のことじゃないんです
自分の子供が死んだ そうするとソーカパリッダワーナが生まれるんです
死んだのは自分じゃないんです
子供なんですけど だからソーカパリッダワーナの場合は地震の例出したんですよ
ドゥッカドゥーマナッサというのは自分に起きた出来事なんです
事故 地震が起きて自分の足が飛んじゃったと
命は助かったんだけど
足はがれきの中にあるんだということになったら
それは自分に起きたことなんです
その時はドゥッカが生まれる
すごく痛いんだからね
それからドゥーマナッサは精神的にもすごく悲しみが生まれる
その二つ ですから ソーカパリッダワーナっていうのは
外に起こる出来事で ドゥッカドゥーマナッサっていうのは自分に起こる出来事で
これどちらにしたっても
人間は大変苦しみを味わっちゃうんですね
いいものじゃないんですね
人間の幸せはそういうことによって
人間の安らぎ 心の安定っていうのはそういうもので
ものすごく壊れてしまうんですね
自分の子供死んじゃったら
死んだのは子供だから俺には関係ないんだと思えます？思えますかね？私には関係ないんだと
なんで私は悲しむんですかと
全然そんなことできないでしょうね
ですから 人の不幸も自分にはものすごい心の安定
安らぎを壊してしまう
自分に起こることも そうやって心の安定
それどちらにしたっても乗り越えることはできますね
心の安定 安らぎを壊してしまう
自分に起こることも そうやって心の安定
安らぎを壊してしまう
それどちらにしたっても乗り越えることはできますね
ドッカドゥーマナッサーナン アッタ ガマーヤ
アッタ ガマーヤという言葉の意味はやっぱり無くすという意味なんですけどね
こちらも消えて消えという言葉書いてますけどね
まあだからといって悟った人にぶん殴ったら痛くないんですよってということはありません
身体の痛みはありますけど
ただ身体の痛みだけ 精神的には痛みはない
全くない まあそういうことだから
やっぱりアッタ ガマーヤ
消えるということを使わなくてはならないならなくなったでしょうと思います
ウレーカニシュニッバーラは乗り越えると
外のことだからね それに対する自分が感じる
その状況を乗り越えて対症する
で 痛みに過ぎたっても
もう瞑想の技を身に着けている人々はね
まあいろいろできます
体の痛みに過ぎたっても
まあ瞑想の技を身に着けてるんだったら
まあもう何のことないようにすることもまあできるし
で あるいは別に痛いぐらいはなんだいということでいることもできるし
痛みは完全に消すこともできるし
消そうと思えば それはあの
まあ瞑想を達したところのことで
だからこの それも俗世間
俗次元で考えると困りますけどね
ですから この ドッカはまああったりなかったり
ドーマナッサはまるっきりない
ドーマナッサっていうのは落ち込むこと
悩むことですね 暗くなること
それは全くない 明るい
病気になって倒れても
で 心の明るさは消えません
体の痛みっていうのは
まあその時と場合によります
で 体の痛みはもうどうしようもなく
まあなんとか止まりたい
止まってほしいなと思ったら止まることもできます
それはそれほど複雑なことではなくて
論理的には説明できます
で まあ痛みっていうのは体の感覚心が受けることだから
認識することなんでしょうね
だから認識しなきゃ 痛みはなくなったというか
もうそれは関係ない だから麻酔かけるところはそういうことをやってますでしょ？物理
物理的に お腹を切ってますけど
この人は痛いと泣くのは知ってる時でしょうね
知らなきゃいいでしょ
あなたは ということで
知らないようにしておく
患者さんが知りません
だから痛くはないんです
知っていたならば もう痛くで死んじゃうんです
それで麻酔かけないで
いろいろほんのちょっとのこのマイナス上げるとかね
やる場合ありますね このちょっとした外科的なちょっと治療とかね
それやる時は先生はよく喋るでしょうね
なんか何か喋って 何か話題を変えて
まあその人はそこまで分かってないんだけど
とにかくこの人で痛くてこれから叫ぶだろうというぐらい分かってるんですね
そこで話題変えちゃうんですね
何か話を聞く 世間の話とかね
そこで例えば指を何かで切って
何かもう何か引っかかったのだったら
それ切って取らなくちゃいけない
取れながら野村沙知絵さんがね
副市長になったね あれ悔しいですねと言いながら
それちゃっと終わってるんですね
そういうそこに頭行っちゃうんですね
患者さんの で それでもう終わってるんだと
もう痛いと気がつく前に仕事を終わってるんですね
だからそれぐらいのことなんですね
痛みっていうのは体の
気になったら痛いんであって
気にならなかったら痛みがないんです
だからそこら辺は自由自在
で 体の感覚は厳密に見てみようという風に集中力を育てると
体全体的に痛みの塊で感じる時もあります
基本的に細胞っていうのは痛みで生きてるんです
みんな痛みは消えてほしい
消えてほしいと思うんだけど
それだったら死んでください
痛みは消えません なぜならば
細胞っていうのは痛みで生きてるんで
他の感覚はありません
この楽しい感覚 快楽感覚は細胞にないんです
神経細胞に感じられる信号は決まってるんです
それは痛みという信号だけなんです
神経細胞の他の情報は伝達できません
我々はいくらコンピューターであれテレビであれ
いろんなものを持ってますけど
そういう電気部品に動く信号は電子だけでしょ
他のものに全然流れません
全ての機械の中で電子だけ動いてるんですね
そういう感じで機械は様々
テレビはテレビで コンピューターはコンピューターで
ステレオはステレオでいろいろ仕事をやってますけど
でも中に流れるのは電子だけ
他のものは流れません
ですから 体の中に流れているのは痛みという情報だけなんです
そこはまあいろいろ違うということで
テレビの場合は映像をするは
ステレオの場合は音が出てくるわと
扇風機の場合はもう扇風機
羽根を回してもらうと
電子レンジの場合は電波を出して
また暖めてくるとか いろいろ仕事は変わりますけどね
ですから この仕事変わるだけ
だから我々は楽しいとか気持ちいいとか言うんだけど
この気持ちいいっていうこと自体が痛みなんですね
例えばマッサージしてもらうと
あの気持ちいいと で 痛みはあのちぎるは首になることは痛みではなくて
普通マッサージしてもらうと
もともと痛みがあったならば
気持ちいい 気持ちいいと言うんですね
でも本当はマッサージ自体はすごく痛みなんです
体で痛みない時 マッサージしてもらうと
もうあまりいい気持ちになりません
かなり痛いんです 体がこうってこうってもどうしようもない
普段も痛い 歩く時も座る時も痛い
それでマッサージしてもらうと気持ちいい
気持ちいいと でもその気持ちいいという感覚
ほとんどそれは嘘であって
相対的なものであって
ですから このしっかりと体を瞑想で観察しちゃうと
体全体的な ただ痛みの塊で生きているんだということのことわかりますよ
そうすると恐怖感が生まれてくる
私はこれでもて他のところで生まれてきたっても
心が痛みで動いてるんではないかと
銃だからね 十ということは零だな
だから天国に至ってもとんでもないことだと
あるのは痛みだけやと
そこで恐怖感が生まれてきて
解脱の方向に心が心向くんですね
だからほんのわずかな痛みが出てくると
瞑想は無茶苦茶にして
もうわがまま言ったりして
そういう根性ない人はもう最初からもうもう
失格なんですね かなり根性は必要なんです
ですから 体の病気治すために
痛み治すためにとかね
瞑想をよろっぱどにやってますけどね
それと仏道はもうかなり隔たりが違う次元なんですね
単なるこの不治のね まあ痛み治すためにとかね
ヴィパッサナーできますよ
何のことなく 末期的ないろいろ病気になったりしてね
まるっきりこの薬も効かない病気もあります
それでも薬さえも効かない病気でも体が痛いと
もう治療ないんだから
みんな死ぬまで待つしかないんですね
なんか筋肉にそういう病気も出てくるみたいですね
どう見てもものすごい我慢できないほど痛みが生まれてくる
なぜ痛みが生まれるかと
さっぱりわからない 立っていても座っていても強烈に痛い
じゃあ麻酔効きますかと
モルヒネ効きますかと
効かないんです モルヒネなんか
だから完璧な麻酔かけちゃったらもう死んだと同じだからね
もう大丈夫ですけど でもそれは体にすごく危険であって
命にもすごく危険であって
この手術とかもうどうしようもない時しかそれは使わない
全身麻酔かけちゃったら
麻酔医師がいつでもそばにいるんですね
彼が目覚めるまで責任持たなくちゃいけないんですね
目覚めて自分で自力で呼吸するところまで来て
反応を見て名前を呼んでみて
名前を呼んだら目でも開けてみると
まあもう OK ということで
もうそれで終わりなんです
そこまでそばにいるんです
だからそれぐらい危ないことなんですね
大変な危険なことで ほんのちょっとのことで死んじゃいますよ
全身麻酔っていうのは
あれほど危険なことはない
ですから ああいう痛みの場合は
モルヒネみたいなこの神経を鈍くするぐらいしかできません
でもそれやったって身体は生きてるんだから
体から情報を脳に行ってるんです
その情報全部痛みなんですね
だから薬効かないという病気もあります
薬は効かないと だから本人にとってはもう地獄でしょう
そういう場合でもヴィパッサナーの技を使うとかなり落ち着いていることはできます
この客観的に見ることで
この客観性心ができてしまって
で それでこの あ それぐらいかということになってしまっちゃうんですね
だからこの瞑想 一応はね
まあできる人にとっては
この まず痛みっていうのは体全体的に出てきて
自分自身がもう落ち込んでしまって
どうしようもなく手も上げられない状態になってきちゃうと
この客観化するんですね
その痛みを どんどんこの局部に持っていくんですね
集中力を 大雑把に痛い痛いではなくて
どこか どこか痛いかと
どこですかと このどんどんどんどんその場所を
その厳密なところにスポットに持ってくるんですね
そこで あ ここが痛いと
で そこから自分の あの主観的な感覚を
まあ放っておきましょうと
そうすると このそこら辺の痛みは
本当はそれでもあるんだけど
別にまあ大丈夫やってことになってしまっちゃうんですね
で これに例えるで言うならば
この光は一番いい例えなんですね
この部屋は明るいんだと
ちょっと暗くしようと
じゃあここら辺ちょっと何かスクリーンを張って
やっぱり光が届くんだ
まあもっともっと黒い
黒い色のスクリーン使いましょうとかね
やっぱりこちらから入るんだから
これを塞ぎましょうとか
大変な仕事でしょ で ヴィパッサナーっていうのは
部屋は明るいんか じゃあなぜかと
そのスポット探すんですね
例えば夜だったら あ これ電気つけてるんだ
ここが明るいんだと じゃあこれ消そうと
だから例えばスイッチはわからない
だったらこれをなんとかでかぶっておけば
暗闇が得られるでしょうに
だから光出しているものを
それをなんとかでかぶっておけば
もう暗いと そういうやり方なんです
そうでないと光だから全部どこにでも広げていって
わけもわからなくなっちゃうんですね
だから痛みも同じで どこかで生まれたら体全体に広げてしまって
もうみんなもう終わりだよと
もう倒れてしまっちゃうんですね
どうしようもないんだと
で そこはこの普通の人の世界で
ヴィパッサナーはどのように管理するかというと
まあ探していくんですね
その局部 この発生源を
オリジンのね そこ あ ここから生まれてくるんだと
そこでそのスポットを抑えることもできるし
見つかったらそれなりに対処法もできますから
それは一番簡単な方法
やりやすい方法 もう一つ
そのやりやすい方法は
それほどやりやすくないんですけどね
で それは見ないようにする
で 例えば足がひどく病気になって
もう痛いと 触っても痛いと
その人にとっては足だけじゃなくて
頭のてっぺんまで痛いんです
痛みが生まれたら体全体的に痛いんだと
電気と同じく全部広げてしまっちゃうんですね
そこで足だけに持っていって
足も全体的に痛くないでしょうと言って
その場所だけに持っていって
局部に持っていって あのひとりは昔一回瞑想会やったところで
このどこで言ったっけ？あの熱海ではなくて
熱海の山でどこかで あのハタノさんとやったでしょう
どこでしたっけ  観音  観音
で あの足一つない人が来ていてね
で 一人でものすごく頑張ったんですね
だから私はあなた歩くこととかね
もういい加減いいんだよと
別にやらなくても  1本の足だからね
左右はもう当てはまらないしね
でも彼がなんで私だけ特別っていうことで
1日2日頑張って かなり精神的には結構もうかなり楽しいところまで進んじゃうんですね
瞑想は  2日  3日ぐらいでしたかな
だからみんなで喋る時も
彼はまあ言うと まあなかなか進んでるなとわかるんですね
本人も結構進んでいましたし
まあそこはこの見方なんですね
だから私は今まで今説法する見方っていうのは
私から全然聞いたことがないのに
何のことなく本人が言うんですね
まあものすごく痛くてもうできませんでしたと
でもとにかくやるぞって俺やると
まあよくよく考えると
痛い痛いって毎日痛いわけでもないんだと
24時間痛いわけでもない
なんでそれぐらいのことに
そこで時間的に絞っているでしょ
私は体が痛い ダメやというふうなことじゃなくて
人には 20時間あって
じゃあ 20時間痛いかというとそうじゃない
それで時間的に絞っていって
それから彼がそういう時間的に絞っていって
空間的に絞っていって
これ誰からも教えてもらったわけじゃないんです
真面目にやってくると
そういう智慧が開発されていくと
そういう噂は何のことなく身についてしまうんですね
そこでいきなりもう痛みも飛んじゃって
誰よりも楽しく楽に瞑想しているんですね
何の嫌な顔もなく ものすごく明るくなってしまっちゃって
ですからまあ そういう世界はね
自分と一体になってくると
いつでもそれは消えないようにはありますね
だからこの時間的に絞ることと
空間的に絞ってスポットを見つかると
スポット見つかったところでも
それから時間的に見ると
いつでも痛いかというとそうでもなく
痛みはそれなりの波を打っていくっていうことはわかりますね
さらに進んだらもう一つわかるんです
ここに心が行くんだから痛いんであって
そこに心が行かなかったら痛くないんです
わかりやすく言えば その場所を自分が知ってるんだから痛いんであって
知らなかったら痛くはないんです
だから他のことを知りましょうと
他のところに集中力を持っていく
だからお釈迦様やら他の阿羅漢たちやら
ずっと苦労して苦労して説法するは
歩いて歩いてるはね 毎日毎日毎日
1日も休みはないし 日曜日もないし
祭日もないし だからもうかなりそれからといってね
ちゃんと栄養をもらう
食べ物もらうとかね そういうこともないし
楽に寝るとこもないしね
あったりなかったりのバラバラだからね
大変残酷な生き方でしたからね
それでもカタカタ体カタカタすかれると
意識は体から完全に離れた
離れて体を置いておいて
意識は別流れるようにしてしまう
その間は体がない その人にとっては
体があるっていうことは知らない
他のことで忙しい その間は体って普通の植物だからね
それなりに落ち着いてきます
ですから 例えば 1時間ぐらいあれば
この痛み この怪我は落ち着くだろうと思ったら
1時間ぐらい心は他のところに持っていけば
あまり苦しみを感じないでそこをコントロールすることができます
そういうふうに身体的な痛みも
この瞑想の達人たちには柔軟にコントロールすることはできます
だからといって この奇跡みたいな感じで
私にとっては痛くないぞとかね
火を触っても火傷しませんよとかね
切っても痛くないよ そんな催し物とかはまずやらない
それから自分が病気になる
と自分だけ得したようなことでということもしません
だから やるかやらないかっていうのはその場で決めるもんなんですね
でお釈迦様の場合で言えば
時々お釈迦様は病気を寸時に治しちゃう
病気でももう歩けないのに
寸地に直して 何のことなく元気で活動している
ある日はもうそこをやめて
もう横になって もう一回咳きりが出てきて
もう半年以上かな 誰にも会わない
全く誰からもみんな追い出しちゃって
で 一人で寝たきり状態で
普通の病人としていたんですね
だから他のお坊さんたちはもう悲しくて
もう面会もできませんし
お釈迦様といても人が来ること自体すごいうるさいんだからね
何もしてお釈迦様にしてあげることできないでしょう
お釈迦様がしてあげることばっかりだから
だから行ったら何か指導しなくちゃ
何か喋らなくちゃいけない
でお釈迦様もあんた方はもう出て行けっていうことで
でお坊さんたちもやっぱりそういうことだから
もう自分の先生だからお見舞いにぐらいは行きたいんだけど
やっぱりそれでも迷惑ということで
まあかなりもう必死に思い思いながらも
もう会うことはなし で
そこでずっといていて
だからその時もお釈迦様
自分の心のエネルギーでね
すぐ病気を消すことはできたのにやらなかったんですね
後で言ったらこれ治りっこもないんですね
80歳でしょうし あ まあこれはまあいくら待ったってよ
もうこれは治らないんだと
でもすぐ治ってもらったんです
寸地に もうなりました
じゃあまあ出かけましょう
そうやってその場で その場で
お釈迦様はとにかく最後の倒れて
倒れて死ぬ瞬間までやりたかったんですね
時間ないんだからね  1日でもみんなに
そのとてつもないこの真理を
やっぱりできるだけいろんな言葉で話しておきたかった
残したかったというかね
だから一つの説法だけして亡くなってもいいんだけど
これで誤解するんですね
あれほど 45 年間お話したのに
もうきれいさっぱりみんな忘れて誤解しちゃったんだから
だからやっと経典一部がね
パーリ語でも残ったんだから
今私はそうやってね 放り出して放り出して発掘するような感じで言ってますけどね
大変なことなんですね
まあとにかく まあこういう心の体の痛みとかね
その場でその場でまあ
治すか治さないかっていうことはね
できますけど それはドゥッカドゥーマナッサーナアッタガマヤということですね
で ニャーヤッサアディガマヤ
ニャーヤって何ですか？ってパーリ日本語訳は
勝利  勝利ということですね
そうですか 言ったの？ん？全然話聞いてない誰も
30 分でこの経典は終わってみせますよ
それだったら  1ヶ月が 3ヶ月がかかるんじゃなくて
そう 少々真面目に勉強しといてほしいんです
もうずっと何年間も喋ったんだけどね
仏教に対する知識理解っていうのはほとんどまあ 0
その中心からなかなかずれませんだからね
それで困るんです で まあニャーヤっていうのは
日本訳では勝利という風に書いてます
で  文字通りにそれでいいと思いますね
こんな言葉は これ注釈書では違う意味あるだろうと思いますけど
八のちゅうは何でしたっけ？勝利というのは
八正道の正徳のために
八正道の正徳のため だから八正道といって書いているのは八正道ですね
だからこれは伝統的な注釈の訳八訳
八正道を身につくためにということで
だからこのサティファッターナというこのこの瞑想法で方法でないと八正道は身につかないんだと
八正道を実践した人っていうのはならないんだというふうな意味なんですね
だからニャーヤに対して説明したかったんだけど
あまり面白くないと思うならば
普通のテキストを読んで意味を言って終わっちゃいます
ニャーヤっていうのは
結局このまあ八正道でもいいんだけど
論理ということでもあるし
あの ものの在り方というもあるしね
だからもう自分に対して
世間に対するもう何かこの方法というかシステムというか
何か論理 論理的に何かあるでしょう
世の中に どのように現れて
どのように消えるかという
このみんな知りたがることはあるでしょう
私は何ですか？と どのように現れたかとかね
何者ですか？とか 普通にみんなこういうことを考えちゃうんですね
だからアダムというから人間ができたんだっていうのは一つの答えなんですね
私は誰ですか？という質問に
あ こういう風に現れてきたんだと
だからアダムイブの物語は
その文化系の人々にとっては勝利なんですね
それで存在の説明できます
なんで女性の方々は苦しんでいるんですかとかね
もうなんで男性はもうずっと女性のために一生懸命もう命かけて頑張ってるんですかと
だから世界のすべての財産が
使っているのは女性であるでしょうし
まあ男はいくら苦労して仕事自分では贅沢することは納得ないでしょうし
全部女性のためにやっているでしょうね
それなのに女性は逆にもう差別されてるんだ
いじめられてるんだ もうああだこうだとか
ものすごく言ってる 言ってるところ苦しんでるっていうことなんですね
あれほど世界の財産を無駄に使っているのに
自分たちはいつでももう追い出されているんだとかね
苦しんでるんだとか 差別されてるんだとか
いろんなこと言って苦しんでるんですね
それは現代社会はそういうことで
どう見たっても 昔からもう男は女のために必死で
もう死ぬ瞬間まで頑張っている女の人はどれそれ贅沢できるかというと
結局は贅沢できない それでも子供もなくちゃいけないんだとか
子供を産んで育てなくちゃいけない
するとそこに引っかかっていくんですね
なかなか逃げられないんですね
だからこの そういうことで
自分には自由がないんですね
女性には自由になりたいんだけど
ならないんです 子供を中に入れたら
どうやって自由になるんですかね
それでも引っかかっちゃうんですね
そこでばあちゃんになったって
孫がついてるんだから
そういうことだから なかなか自由になることはないんですね
子供の関係で  男はすごい自由な関係を持ってるでしょうね
だから男にとっては子供いることは楽しいだけのことなんですね
子供いることも楽しいし
孫がいることもこれまた楽しいし
女性にとってはもう楽しい世界じゃないんです
それすごい神経かかって
一人になって もうもう自殺行為みたいなもんなんですね
で まあそんなものには簡単に解決する方法っていうのは
いくらで仏教だったらね
そんな何のこともないんだけど
一般の社会のそういう技術でしょ
そこでヨーロッパ文化というか
中東文化はアダムという物語で
それ解決しますね それはアダムとイブの間で起きた出来事でこうなっているんだと
今更どうしようもないんだと
やっちゃったってわけだからね
そういう悪いこと で そうやって
それもその人々が妄想で作り出した勝利なんですね
それは正しければ まあその方法で心の安らぎを得なくちゃいけない
で ヒンドゥー教だったらまた違う勝利を言ってるでしょうしね
そうやって じゃあ科学者になったら
科学者は違うこと考えてるでしょ
科学者は物質だけ見てだけ見て
それで物質はいろいろ組みかけたところでアミノ酸が出てきたんだと
で そこでこの原始的な生命体を見たりして
その生命体からどのようにこの今の複数の複数なね
生命体が現れたかというストーリーを語っていて
そこでアミノ酸と遺伝の物語になっているんですけどね
そうやっていろいろみんな勝利だなと思うことは
まあいろいろ喋ってます
だからわかる だからそこまでの知恵があった上のこの経典なんです
その知識なければ ここからこの経典の意味がないんです
ですから なぜアダムの物語は間違っているかというぐらいのことはわかってないと
なぜヒンドゥー教のガンマ論が間違っているかと
間違っている なぜ間違っているかということを
その人々の思考の方法の問題であって
その人にはあんた馬鹿者よというのは失礼であって
人間侮辱することであって
その馬鹿者ではなくて
あなたはどのようにその結論に至ったんですか？どのように考えたんですかと
この認識学的にその人と対話しなくちゃいけない
そうすると必ずヨーロッパ文化の人が言うかもしれませんね
だって私が今ここにいる
それ確かは確かですと
私はここにいるのは私の両親がいたからでしょうしと
両親にはもっと両親がいたでしょうしと
そうやって考えると 最初は誰ですかということになるんだと
だから最初にいた人間にも両親がいると思ったら
それ最初じゃないんだからね
ですから それは誰かが作らなくちゃいけないでしょ
その人が神にするんだと
その人々そう考えてるんですね
その考えのどこが間違ってます？私は今日は答えません
だからまあそれぐらいのことを理解した上のこの経典なんです
だからお釈迦様だったら
あんたは本当に正しく考えてないんだと
ということはちゃんと
あだむゆいの話ではなくて
あなたの考え方がね そういうふうに考えると
ちょっとここら辺が間違ってるんじゃないかと
だから一つだけ反論言いますけど
例えばあの 自分がいるっていうことは
自分の先に二人がいることであって
で 二人がいるっていうことは
その二人のより先に四人がいるっていうことなんですね
ですから 自分の視点 視点から逆に行くと数字が増えるはずなんですね
だからその人はなぜ数字が増えないかと
増えるんじゃなくて減るんだということを証明し
証明しなくちゃいけないんですね
数字が増えるんです ですから
一人にそういう こういうわけで
最初に二人だけでしたよと
ことにならないんですね
その点でも考え方は良くないんですね
で まあそちらにまた反論がありますけどね
一人の二人がね 子供を十人作ったらどうしますかと
で 十人作ったらそこは十人増えますけどね
またその十人に結婚するために
また他のところで十人もつなげないといけませんしね
で 十人と一人が結婚したら
十人の女の子と一人の男が結婚したら
まあそこでかなり数が増えますけどね
まあとにかくそういう考え方はしっかりしないですね
まあまあとにかく それぐらいはわかるのは
自分の今の現在置かれている状況から過去を推測しているんであって
実際の経験がないこと
証拠ないこと あくまでも推測に
論理に頼っていること
あくまでも論理に頼っているんだから
純粋論理だから 認めない
数学だから 数学だから実際の情報と違って独立して走っちゃうんですね
ですから事実に合わすと A
はBですよと AイコールBっていうのは抽象的にはありえますけど
実践的には大変なことになるんです
ありえないんです 実践的にはそれは
あの 何と言いますか トートロジーなんです
[終始効果音]Aは絶対的にBですよというならば
スマナサーラは絶対的にスマナサーラですよということなんです
スマナサーラはスマナサーラですと
だから最後のスマナサーラを前に持って行ったっても構いません
スマナサーラですと言ったのはスマナサーラですよということですから
トータルで言うとそれは何の意味もないんです
でもそっちだけ見たらAイコールB成り立つんです
実際の世界では成り立たないんです
犬は犬だから犬ですよと言ったって何の意味もないでしょうに
どういう言ってるんですかね
犬は犬だから犬ですよと
何か言ったんですか？その人
そういうことで純粋論理持ってるんだから
そこはもうアウトということになっちゃうんですね
まあとにかくこの勝利というものを身につけちゃったら
このかなり鋭く物事を見えるはずなんです
ものの構成システム もののあり方をきちんと知ったことになります
それ知ったらもう知るもの何もないんです
すべてのもののあり方もう知ったぞということだったら
もう知ったそうわかったそうブッダになったぞとは言えますよ
またもうちょっと知りたいものが残っているんだとかはことにならないんです
だからニャーヤ ザプリンシパルということなんです
先生ですか？するっていうのはもののあり方についていろんな考え方があるよっていうありますよね
いろんな考え方が それをみんな知った上で
これこそが正しいと知ることですか
それは後で考えるとそうなりますけど
もののあり方にはいっぱい
いろんな人がいっぱい言ってること自体は
もののあり方を知らないってことでしょうね
だから一番先にこうやって風の例出しちゃったんです
風に何を投げればいいかっていうことをね
いろんなことを言うのは
風には答えがないんだからなんですね
世の中で何かに過ぎて
いろんな人がいろんな考え方を言うのは
結局仏教から言えばあんた知りませんだからと
だから仏教の世界では
あれも勉強して これも勉強して
これも勉強して だから対照してすごい
これはもう世俗 世俗世間ではありがたがるんですけど
どうせみんな迷っている
迷子になっている連中だから
目が見えない人々の間で何探ってみたっても
なんか面白そうにはなります
だから目が見えない人は
像がそう触れば触るほど違う違う意見が出てくる
違う哲学が現れてくる
でも永久的にいくら触っても限りなく哲学が生まれるだけで
やはり答えはあんた見てないという答えなんですね
まだ知りませんと あんたは像のことを
こちらで言っているのは
この触るんじゃなくて
目を開けてみなさいということなんですね
ですから そういう意味で
世の中にある思想に対する別に云々ということではありません
だから本当の答えは何ですかと
結局一体絶対答えは何ですか？と
そこを見つかっちゃったら
もう分かったよという風にも自慢することができます
その瞬間で 他の世の中のありったけの哲学
思想 宗教に対するもうあまり興味なくなっちゃうでしょ
なんか子供の遊びに見えしまっちゃうんですね
それで 元々は哲学者でもなかったのに
論理者でもなかったのに
対話的な性格もなかったのに
一旦悟ってしまえば もうどうぞ来てくださいと
どんな学者にもチャレンジすることはできます
あなたの考え方なんですかと
で 聞いたところで分析してあげて
あなたの考え方はね こういうこういうところ
ちょっと違うんじゃないかなということを示してあげることができます
ひどく悪く言えば 悟った人は他人にアピールするときでも
相手がもう完全にもう間違っているんだっていうことはもうとっくに知ってるんですね
だから サダッタの立場だったら
お釈迦様の立場だったら
あんなすごく落ち着いてるんですね
すごい哲学者が来るんだ
すっごい先生が来るんだっていう
まるっきり関係ないんですね
まあどうせもう一つのお坊さんがアホな考え方持ってくるんじゃないかっていうことで
そこであなたのどういう意見ですかと
で 逆にその人はお釈迦様はどういう考え方ですか？とお釈迦様は答えません
それは話し合いにならないんで
そうすると 全然成り立たないんですね
お釈迦様の教えは何ですか？と
それはお釈迦様綺麗に断ってるんですね
あんたね 私は何を知ってるかと聞くんじゃなくて
あなたはどんな考え方を持ってるんです？あなたが言ってくださいと
そうでないとお釈迦様の対話は成り立たないんです
じゃあブッダの教えを聞いてやろうと
聞いて批判してやろうということはありえないんです
そうせっかくせっかく聞くと
お釈迦様が言うのは それはあまりにも深くて
あなたには理解できませんと
あなた頭が狂ってしまいますよと
ですから 仲良くあなたがあなたの教えを私に教えてくださいと
それで相手方は自分の教えだからね
きちんと丁寧に明確にお釈迦様に説明することはできます
お釈迦様は認識論的にその人の認識過程
知恵が働かせた方向へ
ちゃんと因果法則に則ってないところを見せてあげる
それで対話が終了するんです
終了するんだけど プラスアルファでお釈迦様が答えを出します
その答えは実践しなきゃ成り立たない答えなんですね
ということは こういう風にすれば勝利を得ますよということですね
そう この実践さえすれば
勉強しなくても勝利を知ってしまっちゃうんですね
で 勝利を得た人はもう何のことなくニッバーナ
勝利を得ただけで涅槃ではないんです
世の中のあり様をわかったんだと
でもその人がわかった私も世の中のこのシステムの中にはめられているんだからね
で 次にニッバーナ・サッチキリヤ
涅槃を体得すると 体験する
あの難しいのはそこまでこの
まあまだ四つのサティパッターナは次に説明しますけどね
それから早く読めます
瞑想法だからね この経典のこの大変大事なこのところは
この今説明してたところなんですね
これから実践法だからね
わかりやすい 簡単 単純ですよ
やり方だから 今言ったのは目的
だからオーサッパでもないし
曖昧でもないし 道は ちゃんと達する目的があって
得られる目的があって
そこを目掛けて歩むものなんですね
だから 大殺界であることは禅の世界とかね
大変喜んではいますけど
曖昧であること 大殺界であることね
そういうのは無知の方々にとっては面白いかもしれませんだけど
あの やっぱり知りたいという人にとっては
あまり面白くないんですね
知りたい 解決したいんだと
という人にとっては面白くない
大乗仏教とはもう違うということは
まあ別にどうしたこともない当たり前のことだからね
まあ大乗仏教を攻撃するのは大変失礼なんですけどね
まあ攻撃相手にはなりませんだけどね
で 全く動きが相手になりませんしね
まあそれよりしっかりしたインドのね
昔の宗教いろいろありましたけど
そちらに攻撃しながら仏教成り立ったんですね
だから私もこの もう私が人格的にもうできてないんだから
相手をけなすんではなくて
この誰かがないと この比較してこの差を説明することはできないんです
誰とも比較しないんだったら仏教を語れない
無言です 言うことは何もないんです
誰か問題作らない限りは
だから質問がないと説法は成り立たないんです
それはもう真理の世界なんです
人はもう一応私は神様設定的に信じてますよと
なんとかもう自分のものという何かを持ってこないと
そのものを壊すことなんですね
そこであんた苦しんでるんだと
無執着の世界だからね
一切捨てる世界だから
何にもとらわれない世界だから
何にもとらわれない世界において語るという
何を語るんですかね 語ること何もない
ごく普通のおじいさんで
死ぬまで生活すればいいんです
だからほとんどの阿羅漢たちが阿羅漢になったところで
ごく普通のおじいちゃんになっただけなんです
ごく普通のおじいちゃんのお坊さんになって
そこら辺でお寺の掃除ぐらいして
[笑い]ちょっと昼ぐらいにご飯ぐらいちょっと食べて
もうあまりまあまあグーグーと寝るということもやらないしね
普通にいるんです で ぶつかってみなきゃわからないんです
何かを持って 何かを持ってぶつかってみない人には
さっぱりもわからない
だから一番あのすごい人だと
このわかりにくいのは信者さんたちなんです
仏教の信者さんたち 仏教の本物の信者さんたちっていうのは
全然お坊さんたちにわかることをしないんです
で 黙って言うことを聞いて信頼しているんだから
完璧に ですから もうお坊さんたちでしょうし
お釈迦様でしょうと だから自分の母親言うことよりお坊さんが言うことは信じるっていうことぐらいすごい強いんですからね
そのこの信頼関係っていうのはね
だから あんた何者かとかね
そういうふうに当たったりはしません
ですから 一番仏教の信者さんたちにはわかりにくいんです
知りたくて知りたくてたまらんんだけど
これ禁じられているんですね
聞くことさえ あんた悟ってるんですか？とかね
禁じられているんだから
もうお寺から追い出される可能性もあるし
だからそれは信者さんも聞かない
聞いたらひどい目に遭いますよ
必ず 仏教の基本わかってないっていうことでね
その人はいかに間違っているかと
いかにも高慢で仏道から離れているかということをさんざん言われますから
そんなことは言われてほしくないんだからね
聞こうともしないし そこでみんなすごくありがたがるお坊さんたちっていうのは
よく明確に美しく 面白く
楽しく説法するお坊さんたちなんですね
なんとかのテーマを取ってきて
なんとか経典を持ってきて
かなり明確に もう大変言葉上手で喋ると
そういう人々にもありがたく頼っているんであって
それは悟りの世界とは違うんです
その人の話し方から やっぱり何か言いたいこと持ってるんですね
例えばアビダンマを勉強した人であれば
これはみんなに説法したくなっちゃうんですね
何か持ってるんですね
何か持ってる人は その持ってるものをみんなに見せるんだけど
何も持ってない人はどうしますか？だから悟った人はわかりません
だからお釈迦様のこともわかりませんっていう立場
お釈迦様のこともわかりません
お釈迦様が言ってるんです
どう考えたって これは考えてもわかりませんと
ブッダからブッダのことを考えるなと
では修行してみればね
自分も自分も同じ境地になってしまっちゃいますからね
というふうにあります
悟った方っていうのは
あまりにもごく普通なおじさんなんです
あまりにもがっかりするほど
そんなじじいで困ると
おじいさんだけ？ まあお坊さんであろうと
まあ子供が悟ったらもうそれも同じですけど
まあおばさんもいるかどうかわかりませんだけど
まあほとんど悠々と暇があるのはね
男ですからね やっぱり男の数が多いしね
道程的には男だな  うん
まあ昔はね まあほとんど五分五分で
スリランカの場合は女の方が特にたくさん数が多かったんですけどね
昔は 男よりかなりたくさん出家してしまったんです
あれほど勢いで女性の方々は修行に入って仏教を頑張っちゃったのに
ある日いつかもう消えてしまっちゃったんですね
跡形もなく あれは大変な損だと思いますね
だから未だに活発的なのは女性なんですね
だから未だに仏教は本当に誰が守っているかというと
やっぱりこのばあちゃんたちなんですよ
だから男を引っ張ってくるのもそういう人々で
すごく怒って怒鳴ってね
旦那なんかお寺に行ってお母さんが怒鳴っても
なんかいろいろ仕事をさせたりする
お寺に行ったらかなりリーダーシップを取る人って
男の人はみんなに命令しちゃうんです
あんたこれや あんたこれやりなさい
だからみんなもうはいはいとやってくれちゃうし
だからまあ このおばさんたちが消えちゃったことはね
いたならばもっと形が変わる可能性はよりもっとね
元気で活気した可能性があったんだけど
なんかわけわからないんですね
これが消えちゃったんですね
最初はもう あのサンガミッタ長老って長老と言うんですかね
サンガミッタ阿闍梨にマヒンダ長老が後で来たんだけど
サンガミッタ長老は男性で男の人を出家されたんだけど
そこにサンガ まあ二ヶ月とか三ヶ月ちょー雨さんが出ちゃったら
もう出家したカスの多さがすごいあったみたい
いろいろね あった やっぱりこれ
なんでもね 女性には自由がないんですよ
いくら頑張ってもね 得られないんですね
まあ子供の問題で引っかかっちゃうんです
捨てられませんだからね
だって子供を何人も産んでるじゃん
何人に？どんな割り当て？ そんなに多いんじゃない？ みんなもう子供いる女の人よりもおかしいでしょ
そういう連中は  [笑い] テレビでいろいろ話を聞きますけど
やっぱり聞いたら まあただおかしいだけなんですね
やっぱり一般的にはね
まあ世界もそう言っちゃうしね
まあそんなことはまあ我々も[笑い]ただ無駄話だけでね
同じ話 アメリカで言ったら
僕はごく普通のおじいちゃんではなくて
おばあさんも言います
アメリカだったら men and women といつも使うんですけどね
[笑い]それをもう気をつけて言うんだけど
こいつらバカヤローという気持ちもそれでもあるんですね men
だけで he だけで何が悪いの？って
それは差別しか何にもないんだと
そんなに気にするってことは
あんた病気もいいところやって気持ちはあるんだけど
社会の常識を崩す必要ないんだから he
or she とか [笑い]his or her とかね
を使うんです だから私
使う言葉っていうのは
やっぱりそういう風に
その場でその場で変えますけどね
一般的にはまあ一つの言葉でいいんですけどね
インターネットでも誰か対話する時とか
これあれややこしいんですね
時間もないし 電話つなげてるし
向こう側から何か話しかけたらさっと答えを出さなくちゃいけないし
だから短くしようと he だけ his だけで書いちゃったらやられますからね
[笑い]だからもうまあそんな風にやられませんだから
私は使うな 抽象的な one
one would know et cetera, et cetera.
If one try, et cetera, et cetera. one だからそちらはなし
he も she も  [笑い]